mais voilà
75 millions de disques vendus en 15 ans
1500 cas là à travers la france à
physique de petit prince dei
prématurément et un dynamisme débutante
à son premier bal
voici claude françois cloclo l'idole des
petites françaises
m
mais derrière ce faire son âge de
paillettes et de strass émerge un
professionnel qui ne laisse rien au
hasard
ah ah
claude françois ne se borne pas à
chanter il dirige sa maison du boulevard
exelmans ce qui comporte une agence de
mannequins la production des disques
flash l'avant d'un parfum qui portent sa
griffe et le mensuel podium destiné aux
fans du chanteur savant jour t'es pas
merci à l'eau ou 1 300 faut qu'on
atteigne sa soit avant 4 heures on est
en retard
encore une fois pour le breton
absolument il ya 47 avenue bosquet
demain de marie l'aria sa tombe mercredi
à 19 heures jeux non pas autour du pot
vous savez aussi bien que moi vos
ennemis vous taxent débilité qu'est ce
que vous répondez à ça oui bien sûr
c'est tellement facile il faut dire
aussi que ce sont les adultes qui nous
taxent des débilités alors à ça je
répond d'abord que ce n'est pas un
journal fait pour des adultes que donc
je crois qu'ils ont oublié qu'ils ont
été jeunes et que bon ils ne sont pas
bons juges et de toute façon je pense
que si vous voulez la presse des jeunes
actuels remplacer
ce que lisent et les leurres leur mère
et la grand-mère genre délit ou mac tu
veux si je sais pas si vous connaissez
mais je pense que c'est du même niveau
ce sont des choses bon un peu irréel
bien sûr qu'ils ont toujours représenté
un peu de rêve d'évasion c'est
l'éternelle histoire des bergères qui
épousent des princes et vous alimenter
ce mythe on l'alimentent mais notre
démarche est déjà plus honnêtes parce
qu'en l'alimentent avec des personnages
réels qui vivent de toute façon d'une
façon qui fait rêver les jeunes enfin
les jeunes et moins jeunes d'ailleurs
sont des personnages quand même sont des
stars quand les gens vous demande ce que
vous faites qu'est ce que vous dites
qu'est ce qu'on fait ce que vous faites
vous dans une profession qu'est ce que
vous répondez moi je suis journaliste
dépêche-toi etat belge pouvait pas fuir
plus de quatre fois que ça fait ch et
trier le courrier aux économies partout
oui et envoyer des tweets le nounours
dans les gadgets qu'on a fait si si car
j'adore ça y est ça qu on chez de
teinture enfin plus petit pont petit
gadget l'agenda mais mes stylos téchiné
sont ravis et même le plus long terme en
effet depuis s'ouvrir le pull que j'ai
barré
le trio sicules comme ça sans qu est-ce
qui est encore en lait premier prix
c'est démodé moto de mobixell comme ça
et ça c'est envoyé qui est des gens qui
font quel genre de concours ben les gens
qui font tous les concours que dans
podium
comme quoi une différence plein tous les
cadeaux destinés aux femmes et ça
représente combien de cadeaux d'envoyer
par mois un peu près six mille 6000 km
par mois ça fait combien d'un budget de
combien ça 2 millions de kwh par mois
par mois penser ça lui fait vendre plus
de disques je sais pas je crois pas mais
je sais pas
passé au journal se fait marcher son
journal
le numéro un de la presse des jeunes
applique une recette simple et si on
tutoie les vedettes on s'initie dans
leur existence dorée
les gagnants des concours podium peuvent
même passer un moment en tête à tête
avec leurs stars préférées vous
rencontrer voilà quelqu'un d'argenteuil
viennent ceux ci un livre d'or podium
bleu signé les chanteurs du canal radio
le cinéma d'aujourd'hui et à la fin de
l'année on va faire gagner le super
lectrice de podium c'est encore assez
livre signé par tous ces chanteurs
favoris mais alors qu'est ce que
j'aimais pour faut dire je vais vous
avez envie de m
hélène vous attendez vous savez faire
des photos ensemble là pour le journal
déclarait ensuite vous avez pondu une
pâtisserie les deux on y va donc vous
les rappeler la tête j'ai c'est bon je
ne peux l'apprendre par le par l'épaule
alors on très bonne copine c'est bon là
c'est pas du tout pareil madame françois
vous avez deux petits-fils bien ça ouais
avez vous l'impression qu'on les utilise
beaucoup pour le pour la publicité pour
les journaux d'annoncés très rares en
suisse n'aime pas trop ça mais je vois
surtout les numéros de podium j'ai
toujours de la faute au bond et réseaux
fait parce que j'étais là en vacances il
a profité mais c'est plus on le demande
aussi beaucoup mais on peut pas dire
qu'on les fait tout le temps tout le
temps surtout pour eux vous savez pour
ne pas que à l'école commençait très
fier je suis
est ce que vous avez peur parfois pour
votre fils que le succès
je veux dire non ça m'est jamais venu à
l'idée parce que c'est un bon
travailleur il veut toujours faire plus
ça m'étonnerait vraiment une nuée de
fistules chaque déplacement de claude
françois
certaines passent des jours entiers à
l'attendre des nuits à dormir sur son
palier qui sont elles des folles d
hystérique
une d'entre elles meriam s'explique dans
un livre tout ce qui vient de lui et
merveilleux puisque automatiquement si
j'aime tout ce qui vient de lui et
merveilleux rien il y en a jamais assez
chaque jour c'est un jour nouveau c'est
pas la même chose pourtant c'est
toujours le même mais chaque fois autre
chose on met pourtant je vous donne très
peu
bah oui je ne demande pas beaucoup peu
qu'ils me donnent c'est déjà bien
c'est à dire depuis combien de temps bah
j'avais 11 ans quand j'ai commencé à le
découvrir
et puis j'en ai 20 alors ça fait neuf
ans elle pourrait devrait durer encore
combien de temps va tout la vie parce
que maintenant je sais que il ya que lui
qui compte mais vous ne pensez pas que
j'allais un jour vous marier avoir des
enfants ou en tout cas aimer quelqu'un
d'autre
non je ne vois pas je ne vois pas aimer
quelqu'un d'autre je peux pas je pourrai
pas aimer quelqu'un d'autre et si
imaginons rêvant si lui même âge où
voulez vous épousez est ce que vous
auriez été d'accord non pourquoi
non parce que là c'est pas ça parce que
là mon rêve serait détruit avez vous
l'impression que lui même joue de cet
attachement qu'il a besoin de ses fans
ah oui il a besoin énormément
quelle manière il a besoin quand on est
là il est content il chaussait pas il a
besoin d'être entouré il a besoin de
nous aimer a besoin qu'on l'aide
il remarque quand on ment qui remarque
il a besoin nous sa forme c'est comme
une famille vous avez écrit ce livre
pourquoi ce n'est que vous expliquez
vous même parce que j'avais besoin de
faire le point avec moi-même passé régie
était malheureuse parce que je pensais
que ça nous a permis de faire le poids
oui mais dans un sens
pas tellement ça va ça me profite pas
tellement puisque j'en suis au même toit
toujours aussi amoureuse j'aimerai
toujours resté presque toujours
travaillé pour lui toujours lui faire
plaisir toujours à plat toujours être
près de lui
c'est la seule chose parlons un peu de
votre famille et vous avez l'air de
détester votre père je ne déteste pas il
m'est devenu complètement indifférent
parce que il m'a trop manqué il n'a
jamais été là quand j'en avais besoin
et surtout il battait votre mère
horriblement il la battait et finalement
s'ils investissent été conduit comme un
père je me serais je suis sûr que je ne
serai jamais ta chère claude c'est
peut-être c'est le hasard mais je me
serais cherche dans je crois je me
serais jamais attaché à claude si
j'avais eu ce dont j'avais besoin
chez moi
bon on se raccroche à n'importe quelle
forme d'idéal les uns jardine les autres
jouent aux cartes les troisièmes au
cinéma les autres peigne etc puis défis
qui se raccroche un symbole quelconque
un artiste du quelque chose qui brille
ou quelque chose qui a l'air d'être
toujours heureux d'être toujours en
forme et des et de refléter si vous
préférez une forme de bonheur dans la
société
l'impression qu'une certaine manière
vous l'alimenter où vous quelle est
votre attitude assez neutre des ni pour
ni contre le peuple est contre parce que
ce serait logique il faut pas être pour
parce que sinon je me ferais piétiner
quand je suis entre les deux sont à mes
yeux alors selon mme aimée mais maman en
or ce jeu je suis plutôt plutôt gentil
d'ailleurs une école mais si elle cessé
de tenir complètement un jour vous soyez
pas surpris et en ça me manque de rythme
et un bus a montré est ce que vous dites
qu'est ce que je ferais tout ce qu'elle
entend par exemple elle n'allait pas
pouvoir chanter une chanson toujours le
même je voudrais dans le système vous
l'imaginez ce même public il ya encore
parce qu'à chaque fois on juge ou un
catalogue d'artistes au hasard de sa
minorité
or la minorité des uns et les autres est
différente la mienne c'est des petites
filles écrit l'autre ce sera des
pieds-noirs l'autre ce sera des blousons
noirs etc
mais en fait cette minorité cache
toujours aux yeux du grand public le
vrai grand public qui est dans une salle
qui est le vrai public
si un jour ça s'arrêtait à cinq courses
nous en remettre sans prétention aucune
fugue rue pour plein de choses mais ça
m'amuserait pas n'est rien d'autre nous
amuse je tiens à le préciser je sais
faire des tas de choses elle m'amuse
parce qu'elles sont nouvelles et dès que
je ne sont plus nouvelle m amuse plus
jeune n a rien de tout ce que je fais
dans la vie que le fait de chanter de
créer de deux composés d'enregistrer de
faire cela
la gloire fait rêver elle semble si
facile si proche à la portée de la main
chacun peut se dire et pourquoi pas moi
disons que j'ai des choses à dire et je
dirais comme ça j'ai pas dis pas comme
ça jérôme enfants la plupart des tacos a
voulu nous montrer ce que vous savez
faire
oui je vais dire quoi chanter mais un
petit bout un tout petit bout de chanson
un petit boulot comme d'habitude puisque
on vient de perdre son latin midi je me
lève je te bouscule ne te réveille pas
comme d'habitude à main caresse les
cheveux presque malgré moi
et tandis que sur scène et argus ii mis
stratagème pour plaire séduire et
s'attacher les coeur d'un public
versatile jeune fille poursuit
invariablement leur chimère
le dos
un habitué